he's the beat writer for the Oakland
Tribune Bay Area newspaper group you got
an easy job there Jerry good morning
thanks for joining us how's the the
drama level out there well they can't be
denied media access today and had an had
a little walkthrough instead so we get a
day we'll have to do our drama from afar
wait why were you denied access no I
think it's just a day they instead of
having a regular practice they decided
to have a walkthrough and then they're
not required to open it to the media in
those situations so I don't think
there's anything nefarious at hand with
hard knocks and Antonio Browns
availability I know he loves the camera
but is he officially not in camp I don't
believe so I mean I think I don't think
he's been there for more than a week I
don't believe he's been at meetings he
hasn't been on the field you know
they've been really quiet about it until
after the game on on a Saturday night
where were Cruden came out and supported
him and I I took that to mean they
expect him in soon but I don't
understand this he may be uncomfortable
walking with his feet and he may be
uncomfortable with that new helmet
apparently it's uncomfortable going to
team meetings like why is he not in team
meetings well he's been out supposedly
getting second and third opinions on his
feet with doctors outside San Antonio is
kind of what we've discovered kind of a
one-man band he has his own trainers he
has his own dietician he has you know an
entourage that pretty much takes care of
him
you know the Raiders signed on for
certain things when they brought him in
and I think they're finding out pretty
quick that and you know they kind of
went through this with Marshawn Lynch a
little bit who kind of operated on his
own and Antonia was Marshawn x 5 you
have Gruden publicly backing him do you
buy that I buy that he thinks that
Antonia will be in soon and I and I buy
that when he gets out in the practice
field if he does what we saw in the
offseason and in the brief window we saw
him in training camp and he goes out and
torches somebody for 10 catches on a
hundred and fifty yards younger and will
forget all about all this stuff
when do the Raiders find out about the
hell
issue considering you know he's been in
campers been signed for quite some time
well I think they knew it was a problem
I think during the offseason when they
started they tried to tell him that he
couldn't use it but he was being real
stubborn about it and insisted that you
wanted to use it so they've known for a
while I think it's a situation they've
just kind of managed and they didn't
think it would get this out of hand
you've been around there a long time
covering this team you were there I
think for the first go-round with Jon
Gruden one of the few survivors but Jon
Jon Gruden 2.0 what's the biggest
difference in him I don't know that
there is a big difference in him I think
the difference is in what's going on
around him you know it's different kinds
of players he's dealing with Millennials
so to speak you know I think he has kind
of stayed the same but that you know but
putting a team together and executing
and I mean he knows as much football as
he's ever known probably more but he
still now he's got to show that he can
still put together a winning team and
get them to execute on the field do you
think you can yeah I think he can I mean
if he I don't know that he can this year
I mean their schedule is so so difficult
that you know eight seven wins would be
a really good year I mean they they
leave Oakland after week two and they
don't come back to November crazy so you
know it is pretty much an insane
schedule yeah I think again I you know
I've known the guy for a long time I'm
probably uh probably in his corner I
would say as much as you can be as a
beat writer I'd love to see him do well
it's not gonna not going to happen on my
watch because they'll be out of town
next year Derek Carr in the spotlight
how hot is that spotlight well you know
I think lately
Antonio has taken that a little off him
that seems to be all anybody's talking
about yeah but I you know this is
obviously a big year for Derek I mean I
didn't buy that Gruden was looking for a
quarterback last year I didn't buy any
of the Kyler Marie you're going Askins
talk because that's not his track record
you know john has never turned over the
keys to his offense to a rookie
quarterback now
and they drafted I think the highest guy
they drafted was Marcus Tuiasosopo with
the Raiders and then Chris Sims with
kappa neither of those guys got a whiff
as a rookie and you know I think he had
he got through last year with Derek and
Derek learning the offense and I think
the last thing he wanted to do was you
know tear it all down and start all over
with a young quarterback but this year
he's had it the offense you know it's
been in his hands for a year and I you
know I think this year is a big year for
him talking to Jerry MacDonald he is the
beat writer for the Oakland Tribune
joining us Dan Patrick show covered the
Raiders since 1995 is this a fun job you
know just I was thinking of you know
this is the 25th year since they've been
back in Oakland and if you judge a good
team by a team that's over 500 the
Raiders had four good teams in 25 years
but but it's never been adult but I
didn't know if it's is it frustrating
trying to get information you know with
Mark Davis or you know Gruden loves to
talk so I don't know it's covering the
team while they're like the Patriots can
be interesting occasionally but for the
most part you know your two key
ingredients there don't say that much to
the media or go out of their way to do
that
Gruden's not afraid he'll say something
an Antonio Brown there I just didn't
know if if you can get information out
of that franchise I think it depends on
who you know and who will talk to you
obviously um you know Antonio Brown
thing is you know we don't talk to him
at all we've had him at a you know at a
podium like twice once the one he got
scient once signed to once in the off
season so and he kind of operates on his
own has his own media people and I think
he goes through them pretty quickly so
you know with Antonio it's not we don't
get a lot from him but you know from the
coaches okay and I think they've kind of
it's tightened up a little I think with
in terms of access and getting players
because of hard knocks being around this
year but um you know yeah I think it's
pretty much lighting like any other job
any other NFL job in it because the
whole league is a whole headed that way
in terms of trying to turn off
information whenever they can
well good luck there Jerry fighting the
good fight and thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time hey thanks for
having me
that's Jerry McDonald beat writer for
Oakland Tribune for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]